c'est l'une des nombreuses conséquences
de l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
le f à organisateurs de la ligue des
champions délocalisent la finale de la
compétition
à paris le 28 mai prochain elle devait
avoir lieu initialement ici à saint
pétersbourg la deuxième plus grande
ville russe l'association sportive
condamne fermement les événements en
ukraine l'uefa soutiendra pleinement les
efforts multipartite visant à secourir
les joueurs de football et leurs
familles en ukraine qui font face à de
terribles souffrances humaines à la
destruction et aux évacuations
mais l'uefa est toujours sponsorisé par
le géant gazier russe gazprom détenus
majoritairement par le kremlin un
sponsor qui met le monde du football
dans l'embarras le club allemand de
schalke 04 va retirer le logo de la
marque de son maillot mais aucune
information n'a été communiquée sur
l'avenir de ce partenariat qui lui
rapportent jusqu'à 10 millions d'euros
par saison le football n'est pas le seul
sport à connaître des répercussions du
conflit en formule 1 plusieurs pilotes
sont prêts à boycotter le grand prix de
russie qui doit se tenir en septembre
prochain parmi eux le quadruple champion
du monde sebastian vettel
je pense que cet horrible de voir ce qui
est en train de se passer je ne devrais
pas y participer je n'y participerai pas
je pense que ce n'est pas évident de
faire une course dans le pays en basket
les prochains matches en euroligue
impliquant des équipes russes sont
reportées chez les femmes c'est la
rencontre entre l'ukraine et l'espagne
prévue à kiev c'est dimanche qui est
décalé à cet été